thanks sally  scientist at california's uc davis  developing jelly ice this is something  they say will be a game-changing  material it stays just as cold as  traditional ice for just as long with  one key difference it doesn't melt  that's thanks to a gelatin membrane  researchers say it'll revolutionize how  food is kept cold while being shipped  cross-contamination and inadequate  climate control across the supply chain  are among the leading causes of food  waste  the whole development of jelly ice cube  started with  our concerns over the compromised food  safety and food quality loss caused by  temperature abuses  in the food code chain well jelly ice is  also biodegradable it could serve as a  more sustainable alternative to your  traditional ice pack as well but for now  again it's just a prototype but down the  line christian good to know